so yeah you have to be sensitive to
somebody else in the seam that you're
acting with and if it's not going that
placed and you need to do something to
switch it up so I was doing a movie
called push years ago and chasse Palma
Terry was in the movie and in the movie
he kind of plays like my father figure
and we all know Chazz Palma Terry is a
great actor tall intimidating man very
very generous very nice so in this scene
I am supposed to come in and tell him
that I lost all this money and I need
help and I need I need it I needed him
to bail me out of this life-or-death
situation so I kept coming into the
scene I'm supposed to be crying and this
and I wasn't bringing in Pierhead I was
stinking up the room and I couldn't get
there and so all right maybe you know
take five or whatever I come in
goes what did you say he grabs me pulls
me to him and goes slaps me across the
face wham like this the whole set you
can hear a pin drop and I was like that
started crying he goes what you say he
goes come here and he grabs me again
slaps me again man's got hands you know
wham I'm like oh my god and then I
started to cry and started to get into
it and before you know it I'm like cut
director yells cut he's like that's
amazing thank you so much and I go
outside and I ball cried and I cried and
I cried because I just got my ass handed
to me by a football player in this
business right and I went inside and
Chazz he grabbed me and he pulled me in
and gave me a big huge hug and goes
don't take it personally kid he goes to
NATO slap me and if you go back and you
watch I think it was a Bronx Tale and in
a scene they're slapping each other or
DeNiro slaps him or something like that
and they would keep doing that back and
forth until they actually got into the
scene so I felt it was a huge honor that
he trusted me enough to slap me and then
he told that did the story on Conan
because
Kahneman was like do actors get
intimidated of you
he was like yeah and he started to tell
the story about how he slapped me and
but we got there so he was sensitive to
me and and and he was also being very
generous and helping me it wasn't about
him and I think that's something that we
need to do as actors is-is-is be
generous to the other actor because if
you we both need to look good you know
it's not all about me and my coverage no
like we need to be generous to the other
actor we need to stand there and while
they're doing their coverage and give
them their lines because it's it's it's
the right thing to do it was almost like
a rite of passage and somewhat like he
was like a hazing you know exactly what
I felt it was it was a graduation almost
when I got slapped by Chaz voluntary and
taught me a lot they taught me you know
if it's not going somewhere switch it up
do something different I don't think
I've slapped anybody maybe when I'm like
50 you know Tamim and the new young guys
coming on but I don't take it personally
kid Palmateer you slap
you